in einem satz wie lange glauben sie wird
der krieg noch dauern ich fürchte lange
dauern weil eben amerikaner russland
sprechen wollen und die russen den
westen sprechen wollen und die ukraine
dabei immer weniger eine rolle spielen
da sollten wir gegen wirken das wäre
mein bart herr hardt man muss ja immer
wieder auch das vielleicht einmal klar
ziehen das die amerikaner vor
kriegsbeginn also vor dem 24 als
russland die ukraine angegriffen hat
kein keine schweren waffen in das land
geliefert haben und sehr versucht haben
immer wieder auch joe biden mit
gesprächen diese eskalation zu
verhindern also was glauben sie wie
lange wird dieser krieg jetzt dauern ich
fürchte auch dass wir da noch eine weile
mit diesen schrecklichen bildern leben
müssen ich glaube aber schon dass es
eine chance gibt dass wir an den punkt
kommen an dem protein sagt verhandeln es
besser als diesen krieg mit unwägbaren
ausgang weiter zu führen ich glaube
tatsächlich dass er noch nicht in der
situation ist dass er noch nicht
ausreichend geschwächt ist und ich
unterstütze die these des amerikanischen
verteidigungsministers dass das ziel
schon ist zu verhindern dass putin
weiter aggressiv gegen andere vorgehen
kann ich habe heute mit der vorsitzende
des europaausschusses des georgischen
parlaments gesprochen yakin hat auch
zwei gebiete die von russland besetzt
sind die befürchten wenn putin der
ukraine keinen erfolg hat wird er einen
entlastungs erfolg erzielen wollen das
vergleichsweise schwach bewaffnet und
kleine georgien komplett besetzen das
ist die konkrete sorge toll geworden ich
fände es fatal brechen ich fände es aber
total wichtig denn er ist nicht in der
lage ist so etwas zu tun aber weder in
georgien noch in molde auch wieder schön
zu sehen
wie das vorbild der amerikanische
präsident und auch davon präsident
teilen das nicht was dem
verteidigungsminister dort gesagt hat
sich das inzwischen korrigiert worden es
kann nicht darum gehen jetzt eine andere
großmacht zu schwächen die die gefahren
hat ja unsere militärexperte gerade die
darin liegen unser ziel muss es sein
dass die ukraine diesen krieg nicht
verliert das hier so schnell wie möglich
eine waffenruhe bekommen dass humanitäre
hilfe gibt dass man über wiederaufbau
verhandelt dass man putin einem
fahndungsfoto auch mit den sanktionen
das muss unser ziel sein langer krieg
und das ist der teil den sie immer
unterschlagen wenn sie sollen mal die
polizei und karikieren die leute wie
haben ist die leidtragende des krieges
das er steht nach den frauen wollen mir
von tender ich würde nicht über die
leinwände und herstellen
390.000 krieg sei aber die beste war so
lag jedoch parieren meine positionen die
darin die geschichte hoffen dass das
leiden das will ich mit meinem schuss
nicht dass er sein vermutet dass ich alt
und haben dann leider holztag geheimer
jeder die menschen die moderat
schaukelei das virus ist einfach
ausreden dass jeder kriegstag mir eben
zerstörung vergewaltigen und vertreibung
angst hunger toso verletzte bedeutet und
dass man nämlich das beschäftige und ich
sag es mir auch kraft ballack ich sehe
da ein so seidel weiter stärken als war
das reden was in porträts vertreter des
landes der auch länger gewaltig werden
dass diese neben der straße erschossen
da der letzten jahrhunderte botschaft
die lebensnahe jahrhundert die
schrecklichsten kriegsfolgen
angerichteter den holocaust zu fahren
millionen menschen umgebracht und weiß
das ganze generation verehrt worden sind
nachteilige diese klicks heute mit
keinem stand zu stärken sie sich halten
das schon wieder darum die tiere gar
nicht so was ich spreche von fakten und
von dem was ich in der ukraine gesehen
hat sie kanada zu lassen mich auch mal
ausreden wenn sie in butter gewesen
wären und gesehen hätten wie ich die
leichen auf den straßen die menschen die
hingerichtet wurden das sind die bilder
die wir gefilmt und herr ernst genau
sage ich jetzt von österreich weit es
geht weiter ein russische soldaten
ukrainische städte einnehmen das ist der
große unterschied verlieren werden
russische soldaten dort herrschen und
wenn sie sagen die ukraine soll nicht
mehr waffen bekommen und die ukraine
soll diesen krieg nicht gewinnen dann
passiert das was sie dort auch die
riegel der waffen die sehen wir wollen
das verlängert dieses leid ich sie nein
nein das so gern waffendatei unter dem
zugesehen
aber wir vertreten die wellenlänge darum
jahre um so mehr menschen ständig
wiederkehrend mailand zurück weil sie es
heute versicherer halten als vor sechs
oder acht wochen die situation der
menschen in der ukraine in den teilen in
denen nicht gekämpft das ist eben ein
kleineres gebiet in dem jetzt gekämpft
wird gegenüber dem was vor sechs wochen
der fall war diese menschen fühlen sich
im augenblick gut geschützt durch
unterworfen und ich glaube dass das was
im augenblick geschieht mit westlicher
hilfe in diesem kampf ist besser als das
putin mit seinem ersten anlauf vom 24
februar richtung kiew inklusive gar
nicht wenn er erfolg gehabt hätten und
deswegen
strategie widersprechen der these dass
es jetzt schlimmer ist als es gewesen
wäre wenn wir nicht die waffen und
liefert je länger ich gebe auch zu dass
er wird das
am ende des tages werden wir heute nicht
sagen können ob wir in einem halben jahr
noch sagen können dass es richtig war
das schon so gemacht habe ich sage ihnen
nur nach meiner einschätzung ist es der
bessere weg wenn wir es schaffen dass
die ukraine sich wirklich wehrhaft
gegenüber putin erweisen und ihm eine
blutige nase verpassen so dass sein
appetit darauf politische situationen
kriegerisch zu lösen deutlich abnimmt
das macht nämlich europa sicherer und
nicht gefahr kollege hat den ersten teil
dessen was ich gesagt habe das
unterstütze ich nachdrücklich wir haben
gemeinsam gehandelt das war auch gut so
das hat der ukraine auch geholfen sich
zu verteidigen so stelle ich mir auch
tue was die waffenlieferung ich sage
aber auch die logik die dann daraus
folgt russland zu schwächen oder so das
ist eben eine selbstlose militärexperte
sondern ist gefehlt ich muss vorsichtig
damit sein und das ist ja sowas will ich
möchte dass wir wiederkommen zu
konventionelle abrüstung zu bestreiten
das bedeutet ja eine militärische
schwächung wir müssen wir müssen den
euro zurück in die 90er jahre wo wir
diese großen abrüstungsschritte
hingekriegt haben aber den weg in die
abrüstung hat ja nicht der westen kaputt
gemacht sondern das hat herr putin
kaputt glauben dass wir da habe ich noch
nicht wohin wir vorher die russen zu
schwächen dass sie das können die zu
dieser abrüstung nicht zustande und die
abriss ausstattung kommen durch die nato
nach
dies zustande gekommen weil verhandelt
wurde hat man gesagt hat welche
maßnahmen wollen wir treffen dass diese
gefahr eines atomkriegs sinkt momentan
haben wir eine eskalationsspirale dass
die gefahr eines atomkriegs er steigt
das ist durch das problem ich glaube ich
nicht das ist eine glaubensfrage ein
aber wenn es wenn es dann so weit kommt
können wir sagen sie haben uns geirrt
das ist leider dann zu spät